so yes so today we are talking feature
selection in this talk feature selection
is a topic that's been I think pretty
near and dear to me for a little bit of
time this research that I'm presenting
was as much for the benefit of the
community it's for myself as well
because I wanted to kind of understand
when doing the end to end machine
learning modeling process what types of
approaches may work better than others
so that's what we're gonna talk about
today first though I wanted to tell you
everyone a little bit about where I work
so I work at Southeast Toyota finance
which southeast Toyota Finance is one of
the three primary business units for GM
family enterprises which are three lines
are southeast Toyota which we are the
world's largest independent distributor
of Toyota we cover the states of Florida
Georgia Alabama North Carolina and South
Carolina and we are just an exceptional
great company to work for I mean I kind
of pinch myself every single day I go to
work Jay and family is the 17th best
company to work for a ranked by Fortune
magazine
we've been listed in Fortune Magazine's
top 100 employers to work for
consecutively for the last 21 years and
the people there are outstanding so if
you're interested in learning more about
opportunities with southeast Toyota
finance and Jim family enterprises
definitely encourage you to check our
careers page we're like super awesome
place to work so let's talk feature
selection so one of the article said
really or I should say papers that
actually kind of first got my insight
percolating on feature selection was
Scott Lundberg who's the author of the
shaft library which uses the tree shape
on from implementation he talks about
the inconsistencies of other feature
attribution techniques one of which is
gain which is the default measure in XG
boost and for his most of hit the work
that he presented it was around the
purpose of model
interpretability being able to interpret
model set a global local scale but i
also was interested in you know if gain
is inconsistent then perhaps there's a
better way we can do feature selection
then solely on who's in game so I went
and grabbed data from the Lending Club
dataset it was a two year data set from
2012 and 2013 and Lending Club is a very
interesting data set for me also because
being in Southeast Toyota Finance and
work for a finance company well this is
a finance company as well and it's very
good data on labeled loan outcomes of
payment behaviors of consumers so the
data set was in in essence about 190,000
rows 188,000 loans there were in total
one hundred fifty-eight thousand five
hundred seven ten were fully paid twenty
nine thousand were charged off so there
was some class and balance about fifteen
percent might was the minority class so
that's something I can kind of touch on
a little bit later too so in terms of
splitting the data set I created four
splits of the data split the data into a
training validation test in
out-of-sample test set so the out of set
sample test set was for December 2013
all the other months were either in the
training validation or test set I used
group
excuse me forty k-fold cross-validation
with four seed values to just be as an
extra added step to ensure that model
generalizes I also use that as well to
just optimize the tree count as well so
in essence I grabbed the the best to
recount at each of the different folds
calculated the average for all 40 and
then calculated the average of the four
averages to identify the best tree count
and that was after hyper parameter
optimization with h2s Auto ml which I
can get to in a minute
so the final model was trained on the
training validation and test sets with
model metrics measured on the
out-of-sample test set so in terms of
the
the feature engineering in resampling
that went on first I actually tested not
doing any type of over sampling or under
sampling again there was minority class
represented 15.7% of the data so
generally usually I find over sampling
and under sampling helps with 10% or
less but in this case actually I found
lift with over sampling and under
sampling that would be only in the
training set of the data and that was
essentially the approach that I held
constant for all five experiments
categorical data was both label encoded
and target encoded so essentially target
encoding is going to provide
representation of the mean value which
in this case zero being pay disagreed
one is being charged off that mean
representation for each of the values in
the categorical feature weight of
evidence transformations were calculated
in all features the weight of evidence
is a common practice in for finance
companies for modeling data it's
something that we've done for a long
time which essentially I took the
natural log of the percent of event rate
over a percent of non-event rate so in
that case doing that it's a bidding
algorithm and when you do weight of
evidence bidding essentially you're
going to create multiple bins and if
value has a positive value that would
then indicate that there is a greater
representation of the default class in
that pin if it's negative there would be
a greater representation of the non
default class so let's talk kind of the
process flow for how feature engineering
worked here so first I took the
categorical features and I duplicated
them so all the categorical features I'd
created a duplicate column and then I
went ahead and labeled and coded that
duplicate column the unduplicated
categorical features I target encoded
next I then duplicated off all the
features and essentially calculated the
weight of evidence transformation for
those duplicated features as well and
dropped any features with constant value
the black box that represents experiment
number five so I'm going to get the five
experiments here in a second
so this is actually a technique that
I've thought about for some time as well
and have seen success with where when
you're having a training validation and
test set your training set should be
used to train the entire model your
validation set should be used for hyper
parameter optimization and feature
selection your test set should never be
touched except for evaluated model
performance so with that thought one of
the things that I was thinking about is
it's always important to make sure your
model is going to generalize to unseen
data and could we help avoid any
additional data leakage if instead of my
initial feature selection process of
essentially creating a model off the
training set and measuring model
performance in the validation set what
if instead of doing that I split the
validation set into essentially 80% of
the validation set represents a training
subset and 20% of that validation set
represents a test subset and then do
backwards feature selection only on that
subset of the validation set later at
the end of the the experiment I then
actually then switched when I went to
h2s auto ml to train on the very final
model runs of the entire training set
and measured performance in the
validation set so it's a little bit of a
wrinkle but actually when I show your
results that actually worked best so
we'll get to that in a minute the feet X
packages of package that is also a very
interesting package that has been talked
about for use and feature selection in
this set of experiments feet x didn't
had lift but I think it's still
something that is worthwhile of trying
and I think it may be just a function of
this data set so basically what feet
experts going to do is it's going to bin
on a univariate basis every single
feature into fixed member bins and it's
going to then assign the mean value of
the target variable for each of those
bins for the given feature and plot it
and it will do that on the training set
and then on the validation set and then
I'll measure measure the Pearson
correlation between those two splits so
in
if you have low correlation with say a
correlation like maybe 0.3 that means
you have really noisy data the the trend
line of the training set does not match
the trend line of the validation set and
the premise of this packages they a
feature could still show high feature
importance such as gains the gain
measure but even though Guinea imports
is large the feature is still noisy it
won't generalize to new data and
actually on an out-of-sample test that
could be provide adverse performance so
in this instance it didn't add lift but
I stole them planning on using it pretty
much every time I'm doing feature
selection and having that as one of the
steps that I'm gonna be doing so then
after I used the feet X package then I
went ahead and fit the initial model
gain feature importance values for all
the features using key and you might be
wondering okay so I talked about game
being not only not always consistent why
am I still using it and gain has one
good very nice quality is that it's not
slow so I'm going to talk a little bit
about using Shapley values as I
mentioned from Scott Lumbergh and
Shapley values are much more
computationally intensive so if you are
fitting hundreds of models in a future
selection process if you were to do all
those model fits using chap it probably
would be computationally intensive would
take a very long period of time so when
I'm when I actually built out in this is
in the the black boxes here being
experiment five which I'll get to in a
second when I did experiment five I
started with gain but I then did one
extra thing and I used the xgb fur
package so x gb fur is the are part of a
package which identifies all the
relevant to weigh in three-way
interactions of features in an extra
boost model so why would I want to do
that well it's
also essentially going to be
computationally impossible to
brute-force calculate all the two way
and three-way combinations on say a
hundred one hundred and fifty features
you start getting in the thousands of
features very quickly and it's going to
take the code very long period of time
so if you use XG beefer it'll actually
tell you what are the top 100 two-way
combinations and what are the top 100
3-way combinations of your features and
do the mathematical calculations between
those two way and three-way interactions
and put them in the end of your feature
set for feature selection so that is one
step that I did and then I did stepwise
backwards feature selection with
different approaches but the first part
of that stepwise backwards feature
selection I always use the gain measure
and then reviewed ml flow which I know
there's been some talk about ml flow I
love ml flow like I think it's the best
library it's made my life it's so much
easier there's other libraries that I
think are coming into the community
right now but whatever you use if you're
using actually just saw that sage maker
just introduced a new library for
experiments it use something like that
don't use Excel spreadsheets so and then
after reviewing ml flow plots I then
figured out okay what is the optimal set
of features that I should be using and
then I did something different so I
mentioned I calculated I found the
relevant to weigh in three-way
interactions and then this data set I
used the two-way interactions that were
relevant and then I actually parsed
those out so let's say you'll see my
final model run was at 61 features those
61 features actually reduced down to 20
when I parse them out because it might
be a two-way interaction a feature a in
feature B and then the next feature may
be feature a in feature C well then when
parsing it out actually ended up being a
reduction in total set of features to i
parse that out and then passed those
final set of features into the final
feature selection process which was
either using gain on a stepwise
backwards process with h2s auto
or using Shepley values and a final
backwards stepwise process using h2o
auto ml for hyper parameter optimization
kept the same room time sucks for when I
did Auto ml so all other potential
variables in the experiment were held
constant so and then I should also say
before I did fight the final backward
stepwise process this box right here I
eliminated the redundant features as
well so if there was a main effect
feature or a transform feature I dropped
those the one that was had the lowest
importance so these are the five
experiments that I tested I first
started with experiment number one which
was backwards stepwise with chef next I
did backwards stepwise with Shep and
feat expert then I did backwards
stepwise was gain experiment four was
just a single elimination of the same
kind of features with gain and then the
final step was doing backward step wise
to a chef and that and that one I also
split the validation set
so on the first experiment when I did
backward stepwise with chef and this was
not splitting the validation set what
you'll see here is this plot point of
highest AUC in the validation set was at
170 features that was actually the first
model fit so what actually happened here
was when I went ahead and calculated the
relevant two-way interactions which got
me out to seven hundred features you can
see AUC is lower and AUC never got
higher so in this instance essentially
what I did was ended up staying with
that 175th feature initial model run
when using the feet x package to
eliminate noisy features instead of
starting with 127 features and if
starting with 43 as 127 of the 170
features had a correlation between the
training and the validation set of less
than 0.75 I also tested a correlation
threshold to cutoff at point nine oh
that was actually worse than using a
correlation threshold 0.75 0.75 values
what I used for the rest of that
experiment
so in terms of finding the optimal count
of features backwards with shap so I had
that a hundred and seventy feature first
model run I parsed a and so basically
excuse me what I end up doing and that
that experiment is actually just then
backward stepwise feature selection and
this is the type of plot a scatter plot
that I'll usually see what I'm doing
backwards stepboys feature selection
it's kind of like a reverse hockey stick
where it's going to be pretty constant
and then it's going to start dropping so
what I like to do is choose the model
that's going to have be most
parsimonious and have the fewest amount
of features which provides benefits for
interpretability and also computation
and inference but so in this instance I
actually chose the model at 17 features
perhaps could have also chose the model
24 features but I want my 17 and from
that experiment run I then held that
constant for all five other experiments
so all the other experiments that I
tested I always use 17 features just to
make sure I've had an apples-to-apples
comparisons between the two the
different experiments so when splitting
the validation set there is kind of a
different look here and so this this was
the first model fit at 170 and you can
see them when I did the two-way
interactions we got an A you see down
here right at about 0.5 85 and that I
did backwards stepwise feature selection
all the way down to one feature and
sometimes there's jumps because they're
in this instance between those two runs
they all had a feature importance of
zero so they all got dropped so I'm
essentially iteratively going through
and eliminating the feature with the
minimum feature importance and
continuing that through with the guinea
imports measure King and so as you can
see here right at 60 one feature that
actually was the highest AUC and then
the next step of this experiment was
then to actually parse out those 61
two-way interactive features all
undistinguished and along features which
actually got us down
about 20 features and the other thing
that I should say to that reduced us
down to 20 features was the elimination
of when there was a main effect feature
in a transform feature I eliminated the
feature that had the lower feature
importance so if let's say if the label
encoded feature had less feature
importance than the main effect feature
then I kept the main effect feature so
then another thing I want to do and I
know this is going to be a little bit
hard to read here is I created a linear
model for these scatter plots to see let
me come back to this plot here so you
can kind of see here like you could kind
of fit a linear model to that to that
data so I fit a linear model to that
those those AUC values essentially with
the different feature attribution
methods that I'm testing here of schaap
and splitting the validation set and
that had our square root of point seven
nine three shep and splitting the
validation set with a p-value of less
than point zero zero one and then if I
just did chef alone and not splitting
the validation set the r-squared was a
little bit less at point seven two two
and the p-value is still good and the
less than point zero zero one and then
when I use gain the r-squared is even
lower at point five thirty five those
values were when fitting a linear
regression for the model metrics on a
you see on the validation set for the
runs between six and twenty features and
I chose that because 20 features was the
first run that I had when I split the
validation set so I mentioned I had 61
features I parsed out the interactive
interactions and I also eliminated
redundant features between
transformations and main effects which
got me down to 20 features that's
century wise at that point and six
features was essentially used at the low
point because after I had less than six
features the model really started to
degrade in performance so that
I think is a good measure that of these
different types of approaches that on
this data set that Shapton splitting the
validation set was going to get me
predictable results is I'm going through
the feature selection process in a
stepwise manner so kind of with that
said I've talked about these five
different experiments and it can kind of
come back here again so these were the
five different experiments that we
tested I think what everybody probably
wants to know is like well how did this
actually work so when looking at the
results the best experiment was when I
was doing stepwise backwards feature
selection first with gain and then
finally on the last few model runs with
shap and splitting the validation set
you can see the AUC was at 0.67 for
average precision scores up the highest
at 0.25 one the log losses 0.46 eighth
you might think AUC 0.674 that's not
really that great well it depends I
think that always depends on what the
problem is you're trying to solve so in
this instance again we're trying to
predict people if they would default or
not on their loans being an imbalance
data set it's not something that happens
that often there's a lot of reasons why
people can default that aren't within
the data perhaps when their loan
originated they had this fantastic job
and three months later something
happened they lost their job and maybe
that's why they couldn't pay back their
loans so some of that is always going to
be depending on the problem that you're
trying to solve and that's your model so
only going to be as good as your data
and there's aspects that you might not
have of predictors that might not be in
the data set
so looking at some of the other
approaches to experiment one was the
backwards step voice with shap at point
six five to zero the single step
elimination of features with gain which
is an approach that I think is quite
common and I actually had ranking third
here at Point a you see 0.6 for seven
backwards stepwise with Shep and feat
expose at point six four one and
backwards stepwise with gain was at 0.6
three nine so you can see here in terms
of a percentage difference of what are
those
model runs represent you can see AUC was
just over 3% higher between experiment 5
and experiment 1 and log loss were lower
is better at 10% improvements so that
suggests to me that this approach of
using gain in conjunction with Shapley
values definitely provides a good
opportunity to enhance some of our
feature selection approaches our feature
selection methods that we may employ to
get better model results and I think
those results also show here that
there's a fair amount of variability in
these results here so the feature
selection technique that you employ
definitely is matters and can have a big
impact on how well your model performs
so including conclusion there's a couple
things that I think I want to talk about
first backwards stepwise with chef
obviously I've mentioned was best
results may vary on your data set so
that's I think a very important point to
mention so if this approach worked well
in this dataset maybe on a different
data set
maybe another approach may work better
but I think it's worthwhile to consider
different types of feature selection
techniques in your codebase and tests
multiple different approaches I would
definitely recommend using an experiment
tracking platform such as ml flow for
a/b testing ml flow is it's great it's
super easy it's it's something that you
can use for literally I log I've logged
thousands of experiment runs into ml
flow and this whole ability of being
able to come back after you're done and
just having everything logged and being
able to look at these types of scatter
plots when you have hundreds or even
sometimes thousands of model runs to say
okay that's the best one I really like
this one right here that is really nice
so I would if nothing else I would
definitely have an experiment tracking
platform that you have in your in your
workflow and then
on this fourth to last conclusion gain
provided a performance benefit over shop
using interactions with gain may add
lift so that's something that I think
interactions is a common approach that
we use as data scientists for feature
engineering but it may also be
worthwhile to consider that if we know
that gain is not always consistent at
the way it represents feature importance
values and one of the things to kind of
take a step back here that Scott
Lumbergh mentioned was that what he
found was with gain is that the features
that were actually lower in the tree had
higher importance which gained
essentially provides a measure of the
log loss lift on average that that
standalone feature contributes in the
model where if that feature is removed
what's that difference in that log loss
gain he actually found that features
lower in the tree provided a higher gain
value than features higher in the tree
which doesn't really make sense because
normally when you're thinking about
decision tree the top of the tree is
going to be the feature that has the
most importance in the model so that's
something that I think is really
important to kind of just think through
is that ok yeah gained it can give us a
measure of importance on a global scale
of how important feature is but there
are some limitations with it and if you
do something like what I did where I
created basically interactions of
features that interaction process it's
likely that even though it's not always
consistent it's likely that in one of
those interactions an important feature
won't be omitted and it'll be kept in
that interaction and then later on then
in the feature selection flow I can then
do backward step wise with Shapp parse
out those interactions do backward step
parse on chap
I'm only fitting maybe five or six
models it's not like I'm fitting
hundreds of models and then it may take
a little longer computationally but if I
develop my code in that type of process
it doesn't become a computational
problem where it's taking days or weeks
to complete and lastly I mentioned Scott
lumber use Shaffer interpretability in
like for me that's something that has
been really a great package I really
enjoy using shap for model
interpretability
and communicating internally and
externally the benefits of the package
and how it's really something that kind
of dispels the mission the notion that
these are black box models because
they're absolutely not they're
definitely interpretable so I would say
with that I mean that probably includes
my presentation we can open up to Q&A so
in your results you were bouncing
between it looked like about 55% AUC to
62% AUC have you done this on a I don't
want to call it a like not toy dataset
like have you done this for real and
have you gotten similar results because
I'm not really sure how to translate a
7% jump and now you see in that range as
to whether or not it suddenly makes it
useful like I like in my problems a 62%
AUC is like you still got it you still
have garbage so like like how does this
work for for a larger data set that's
more relevant to what you're doing yeah
great question so I have used this type
of approach before I can't get into too
much detail in the projects and things
that I've used it before but it
definitely has given me a lift in doing
this type of work in I would say don't
get too fixated on the number get
fixated probably more on these
percentage changes so like for me if I
can get another 3 or 4 percent or 5
percent in my Challenger model to my
champion model absolutely worth it so so
yeah I think it's definitely something
worthwhile what was the inspiration to
do the comparison for the different
models for you like using it
it was mainly Scott Lumbergh wrote a
medium article introducing the tree shop
chat package and he talked to quite at
length so encourage you to to google it
still on there it's a great read and he
compared it like the different types of
feature attribution methods that are
used in the benefits of hash app since
it uses Shapley values and it provides
essentially a consistent consistently
accurate he describes a method for
understanding global future importance
and from his angle he was kind of taking
it as well we're trying to interpret a
model to understand what are the most
important features
well feature importance is also a
process that's often used for feature
selection so for me when I'm looking at
that article I'm thinking okay if this
is really not that consistent well then
there's probably some improvements that
can be made in the feature selection
workflow and that kind of was like my
inspiration for going after it alright
thanks again to Ben Fowler for that talk
evaluation of a traditional and novel
feature selection approaches